[Music]
fifty years ago next week Apollo 11
blasted off for the moon over the course
of the Apollo program a dozen astronauts
made the 240,000 mile journey to the
moon surface scooping up hundreds of
pounds of rocks and soil we have a rare
glimpse this morning inside the secure
windowless facility at NASA's Johnson
Space Center in Houston that houses 80%
of the lunar samples brought back mark
strassman suited up to see it inside a
Federal Reserve Grade Bank fault bother
this pic ryan Ziegler showed us the
lunar sample laboratory NASA's
collection of moon rocks in here our
white anti contamination jumpsuits are a
must this is the largest caucuses by far
the largest question anywhere in the
world humanity's first samples taken
from another world older than any rocks
found on earth so this is essentially
the oldest rock from the moon that rock
is 4.4 billion years old and the moon
might only be 4.4 billion years old six
Apollo missions landed men on the moon
their astronauts turn geologists
collected in all 842 pounds of lunar
rock and soil starting 50 years ago this
month
this was the last sample collected on
the Apollo 11 mission and Neil Armstrong
decided that the rock box with the
samples in it looked empty so he
shoveled four or five shovelfuls of dirt
into the rock box just to do it on his
own
Apollo 11 soil sits inside these two
dishes probably the most valuable sample
of the Apollo 11 mission brought back I
could pick one sample from Apollo 11
this is it not a rock not a rock soil
nitrogen pumped inside these stainless
steel cabinets preserves the rocks
inside this display showcases the
collections highlights the lunar Rock
Hall of Fame pretty much rocks as old as
our solar system Apollo's geologic
legacy it's a hands-on collection for
someone with training and three sets of
gloves how heavy is that one this way
six or seven pounds would be my guess
still kind of fun to poke it never stops
being fun it's amazing every day I come
into the lab is just like the first day
many rocks have stories this one
involves Apollo 16 astronaut Charlie
Duke in 1972 of all the rocks collected
by the Apollo missions that was the
biggest there's a great video of Charlie
Duke rolling that up the leg of his
spacesuit because it was so big and it
turned out to be a really important
sample it was hard work Duke now 83 talk
to us about rock collecting on the moon
working against that soup was demanding
so after eight hours in that suit you
were really tired you squeezing the
gloves and in and out of the car and
trying to bend over on us so it was
exhausting but worth it the rocks
revealed secrets including the moon's
own violent origin scientists now
believe a mars-sized planet collided
with earth exploding a ring of debris
that formed the moon that was about four
and a half billion years ago I was
significant we're bringing back the moon
rocks the moon rocks taught us about the
entire solar system arguably the most
important geological find ever I'm sure
there were people who'd argue with that
but I think they would lose this corner
houses something special in our top
secret high security don't go beyond
this cord cabinet inside are the final
six pristine moon samples unsealed
unstudied until now NASA will soon open
three of them saving the rest for the
next generation of researchers for CBS
this morning
mark Strassmann at the Johnson Space
Center you know a few years a few months
back I got to go to Flagstaff Arizona to
the USGS to spend time with the
geologist who trained the Apollo
astronauts and they say it took some
convincing by a guy by the name of gene
shoemaker to get NASA to go along with
the rock collecting like the sample yeah
business so to speak so what we'll find
in those in those have yet to be lived
so exciting they're still there I know I
love the way Charlie Duke described
working against the suit
you know pushing it uphill ashamed of
his fans none of the samples it turns
out our cheese the moon is not made
Tuesday on CBS this morning we will be
at Kennedy Space Center to retrace the
steps of Neil Armstrong and the Apollo
11 crew leading up to the moon landing
and we'll bring you a special report
marking the exact moment Apollo 11
blasted off 50 years ago
later that day Norah O'Donnell will
anchor the CBS evening news from Kennedy
Space Center and bring you a CBS News
primetime special man on the moon that's
10 9 central right here on CBS